[Music]
there's a new online trend we like to
keep our eye on these new online trend
that's going viral it's called baby
heading have you seen this it's where
you take pictures of a grown-up and you
replace their head with a baby's head
here's an example on the Internet these
things are everywhere here's another
example I'm sorry my wrong Andy or is
this just creepy it seems weird I I
think people people have way too much
time on their hands I mean we've got
real problems in this country and this
is what you do with your time
[Applause]
and it's just it's just harmless fun
it's no crazier than planking or
Tebowing you need to lighten up pal hey
you asked for my opinion I gave it to
you now you're riding my ass because I
disagree with you I'm so angry with you
I'm not now I'm looking at you yeah I'm
talking with my boo boo in my mouth you
speak very well with that thing in your
mouth I'm confused as to how you can do
it
very confused all right let's talk about
tonight's show I've never been happier
right this is how I see myself
[Applause]
burp ladies and something great show
tonight from Sarah now live Jason
Sudeikis is on the program
[Music]
nothing short of a comedy legend a huge
influence on me and I am absolutely
thrilled he's here Dick Van Dyke
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
music s not speech
[Applause]